[Musique]
Bien que je veuille limiter mes commentaires
sur le procès lui-même, je dirai que ma
famille et moi sommes heureux que
l'attente soit enfin terminée et que le jour
soit arrivé Je me suis assis dans la salle d'audience aujourd'hui et
j'ai regardé l'officier
qui a pris la vie de mon frère
je voulais juste vraiment que cet
officier offensif sache à quel point l'
amour de Floyd avait de la
violence n'est pas la réponse à tout
parfois nous devons prendre du recul
réfléchissez avant de réagir et c'est moi
vous les officiers peu importe ce n'est
pas la réponse
je manque mon  frère mon frère george me manque
comme vous l'appeliez donnerait
la
chemise de son dos à un étranger
c'est comme ça que nous avons roulé c'était lui
il avait ses propres problèmes mais il s'est également
assuré que
personne ne voyait les problèmes qu'il
traversait si vous  traversait
vous ne pouviez jamais savoir ce
qu'il traversait parce qu'il ne vous a pas laissé
voir ce côté de lui
l'officier a pris un grand homme
un grand père un grand frère
un grand oncle et un grand
père il a vraiment pris un grand père  il
était tellement axé sur la famille d'
accord